what's going on people we are going to
watch today from ea
voss new rock stars loki mystery easter
egg
finally revealed infinity war connection
explained
no idea what the hell he's talking about
so let's just find out what's going on
if you haven't subscribed to new rock
stars do yourself a favor there's a link
at the pinned comment and in the
description box
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one of the more mysterious
easter eggs in the loki finale
has finally been revealed and like any
clue we find in these shows this
revelation actually becomes its own
nexus event whose historical
implications extend far beyond the event
horizon
causing me to bolt awake and a cold
sweat gasping
magnificent the loki episode vi opening
imagery packed in dozens of marvel
references
including this mystery ship that many of
us spotted but struggled to identify
right away
loki head writer that's a fantastic form
fans might recognize this ship and quote
it's been in a few things
and we have now learned this is actually
the ship of the collector
tannelier del toro guardians of the
galaxy it was seen
in the background of nowhere
illusion of torturing tavon in order to
trick gamora and the other guardians
in various shots you can see this ship's
golden plating covering its blue frame
and wings extending from beneath the
cockpit and going downward when parked
and this was confirmed by loki vfx
supervisor brad parker in an interview
there was a hidden detail or two there
are a few
little elements that we pass by one
might be the collector's ship um
definitely is brad but we catch your
draft he refers to them as
elements a term used by these movies and
shows editors and effects crews for
marvel studios vast
archive of assets and elements across
properties the collector ship was
designed for
past marvel titles and now shows like
loki have the ability to access the
elements for their shows
what the hell is he doing there i mean
that's a great
excellent question i mean i feel like
you know the collector would have
business
as far and wide as the galaxy can reach
i mean it's cool that we haven't
forgotten about the collector that must
mean he's not dead
yeah plus i mean isn't it somewhere in
the what if promo too
yes yes so you know maybe they just
wanted a really really really viral
hidden piece of advertising for that
maybe it's that version
yeah of that what-if version that
multi-burst one i'm so surprised no one
discovered that already
considering that the ship is right there
play inside of the video
yeah you would think do you think that
would have broken out a while ago but
now this brings up the questions of
what the hell was the collector doing
out here and why was it so important for
marvel studios to bring him back like
this that's exactly what i asked
one of marvel's elders of the universe
alongside the grand master jeff
goldblum's character in thor ragnarok
tyvon dedicates his life to collecting
artifacts
a purpose directly linked to his
immortality and while it seemed like
thanos was about to destroy him infinity
war
this whole interrogation faded away in
red smoke as part
of thanos reality stone illusion reality
stone of course was last seen hidden in
the collector's vault by the asgardians
in the thor the dark world post-credits
scene now notice how after thanos drops
the illusion the collector ship now
appears to be a flaming wreck if that is
the same ship
though we never actually should bonds
remains actually while he vanishes he
does a silly little wave
something i've always loved from the
scene because thanos must have hillary
clinton
from his own imagination like he did
with blocks and ribbons and bubbles but
i've always looked at it a different way
like maybe tavonne in defeat as he
handed over the reality stone
might have allowed thanos to mirror his
likeness so that he could better
manipulate gamora just because that
little wave makes it look like tavonne
might have helped pull something over on
the guardians just based on that gesture
i've always read that moment as maybe
the real devon surviving
somehow and now with this ship's
appearance there's a piece of debris i
think his survival is more likely in the
mcu he is an elder of the universe
now we don't know when this sighting in
loki takes place because
as has been confirmed by the loki head
writer all moments in loki are really
set simultaneously
as all the other moments in mcu history
but in the seconds that we see his ship
it is soaring away from the galaxy that
contained
all the voices we had witnessed
throughout the infinity saga as this
universe condenses in a big crunch
before exploding again in a big bang
that would mean tavonne could have
survived long into the future of the mcu
as we previously knew it into a new
universal cycle
we will soon see one such cycle as the
collector is confirmed to return in
episode 2 of marvel studios what if
actually the latest featurette directly
referenced loki's imagery of the sacred
timeline fracturing as the context
within which what if is taking place
reality is not a straight line every
passing moment
is a chance for a new offshoot a new
variation
in fact there are more realities than
you can possibly find i can't wait for
this show
previous trailers have confirmed episode
2 will feature star-lord t'challa
teaming up with yondu kraglin taserface
and korath
and more on a mission that takes them
into the collector's compound on nowhere
where t'challa will apparently meet
howard the duck and it will end with
t'challa and yondu
tag teaming to fight a version of the
collector who now looks
jacked and wears special armor with
cybernetic enhancements one of the most
interesting things was benicio's body
shot is that the head writer apparently
had to scrap an episode concept because
marvel studios came back to him saying
it was too similar
to half of james gunn for guardians of
the galaxy vol 3.
i wonder how often that actually happens
with these movies at the mcu i imagine
that is a daily occurrence
yeah because we recently learned that
michael waldron had to communicate with
the writers of spider-man no way home
to ensure that whatever he was uh
conjuring up with loki didn't
negatively affect the plot progression
or mess with the timeline events at all
with what's going to
take place in spider-man no way home but
this is the first i'm hearing if this is
too similar to our other movie idea
yeah i guess it's just good that it was
too similar to an in-house movie in that
movie coming out from some other studio
as has happened before actually when gun
heard about this he responded that he
had no clue what this was and he was
real curious about how
that could be the case there was also an
odd report back in 2015 in which zoe
saldana suggested she planned to appear
on a guardian set again with benicio del
toro in retrospect that could have been
the scene that they ended up shooting
for infinity war
or since james gunn has reportedly had
his volume 3 story locked in for several
years half of that script might have
involved the guardians reuniting with
the collector
which is now why this what if episode
casts a collector
instead in this short-lived antagonistic
role
instead of something else that james
gunn plans on doing with him one of the
most interesting things about the
collector in the mcu is a quote from
benicio del toro when he described his
character as a kind of
altruistic survivalist he's kind of like
noah from noah's ark he believes that
there's gonna be
a big catastrophe in the galaxy in the
whole
universe and he's collecting all these
creatures to preserve them somehow so
there's an element of
altruism looking back no he was
certainly headed toward catastrophe of
course thanos snap but based on thanos
sacking the collector's vault and
stealing his most treasured collection
the reality stone
i don't think the collector saw thanos
coming nor was thanos the catastrophe
the collector was planning for
especially since thanos's snap likely
would have impacted half of the
collector's living collection anyway or
even the collector himself
but now based on the collector's ship
appearing in loki
i wonder if the catastrophe he was
actually bracing for was
king in the rupturing of the sacred
timeline because if you go through this
imagery frame by frame
his ship is racing away from the galaxy
and toward
the barrier of a black hole i love that
you're gonna get the hell out of here
it's happening howard get it
you follow my prized possessions i'm
taking you i mean like
in terms of where he sits in the
universe i guess that would make more
sense when you put benicio del toro in
there and he was teased at the end
of which one was it was it thor the dark
world
um i can't remember what that post
credits here was but yeah he
he was teased at the end as one of those
he had a good chunk of screen time in
the first guardians of the galaxy you
always get the impression that his
character was more significant
than perhaps the the movie or the screen
time he had was actually letting on
so i love the concept at least what the
theory is of building this guy
up so much to the point where he just
kind of seems like a small but
significant player
really leading him into being a very
important character down the road yeah
and i mean a talent like benicio del
toro i think is somebody you would
definitely want to expand upon and
explore in this universe
rather than yeah having him just be a
fun one-off cameo or something orders
another black hole which we realized was
presumably tracing the geographical path
one would have to take to traverse
across universes
if one could hypothetically even survive
that journey because we don't see
the collector ship make it it kind of
looks like everything gets caught in the
big crunch in the big bang that follows
and according to physics nothing should
be able to escape a black hole but then
again this is also marvel and
intrauniversal travel might just stretch
out your face a little but i like to
think the collector
did survive that journey and as an elder
of the universe it was his purpose to
survive kang and loki's multiversal
crisis by physically
bypassing the barrier between universal
strands
and escaping the crisis formed when
those strands collide in with each other
and i hope that part of his genesis
protocol
are the members of the guardians of the
galaxy specifically groot which remember
was a specimen that he was notably
obsessed with collecting
what is that thing
there i am group i never thought i made
a group
sir you must allow me to pay you now so
that i may own your caucus
at the moment of your death of course
maybe because the collector knew
that when a groot is destroyed its
pieces become roots
for new life to spawn something quite
useful to someone who considers himself
the noah of the multiverse but what do
you think is the collector's future in
the mcu comment down below
and you can support new rockstars by
checking out our various merch options
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
great video damn that's a really big
easter egg to unpack that visual effects
guy sucks at playing it cool
i'm just gonna name this very specific
thing that it's
not all right guys well thank you so
much for watching and subscribing to
rockstars you haven't done so already
hit that like button check out our local
reactions and last but not least let's
do
david the gandonader recently got two
cats taking care of these babies well
he's got his own new house glad that you
got your little family going i'm really
happy for you that you made this big
move you seem happy
i don't know if you're actually happy if
you're not
you know what you can do you know what a
lot of serial killers do
they start with animals i've always said
that if you're looking to really spice
things up
kill a cat no is what i'm trying to get
yeah yeah killed your cats
yeah i had a really good starting point
kind of lost it or you just
go even further man after your cats get
a dog adopt a kid this is only going to
get better because you kill a kid
that's famous yeah yeah that's the way
to go viral
kill the jock kill a youtube celebrity
mm-hmm and then
boom the more minor the better
that's the way true infamy and fame all
at the same time